sol e 20 e hoje vou ensinar como fazer
um revólver com seis balas
então bora lá proteção - dia o teste
pela turnê ão passo a passo
então vamos lá sol e maio tem que rolar
uma folha com se fosse uma rifa é que
ela das coisas
caso vocês não conseguiu fazer ela vir
aí eu vou deixar um link de inscrição
quando ensina a fazer isso passo para o
final para não conflitar para um celular
e herói foi a volta de modo a fazer um
tubinho está tudo bem fino landu
ensinando um pouco aí para ficar tudo é
importado
aprendo com fita em três partes ou seja
na extremidade na parte central
pegue um pedaço maior e prendendo do
lado do outro
nesta quarta em que voltaram a cancelar
uma folha o modo a fazer um tubinho que
seja maior que o usual aí para vocês
poderem estava um saco de rifas tubinho
jesus vinde normais
nesta parte vou cortar seus segmentos
vermelhos e um segmento azul duro dos
incentivos hoje com cola e cola em
vermelho azul ou seja o azulão vai ficar
no centro do tambor a cair eu preciso é
mesmo pra ficar tudo alinhado
depois é só por um lado e do outro usar
agora uma coletiva propor a volta nessas
partes todas aqui dois tubinhos para
ficar mais forte e diminuir o atrito é
muito importante você expor em si porque
aquela peça vai girar ok então fizeram
atrito vai ser muito complicado vocês
mudarem para a próxima bola é que eu
cuidei dos pedacinhos de quatro centros
escolares de 12 centímetros depois
voltei a colar um pedaço de 45 e partir
daqui para fazer empunhadura da arma
está para ter bastante opcional estou a
fazer mais ou menos possível e quando
volta que vai ligeiramente para trás mas
se vocês quiserem podem fazer direito
para baixo
[Música]
vejam que no início vai ter 45 e no
final de cinco centenas
agora vamos dar dois pedaços de 10
centímetros com o azul e outro formado
depois cole um ao outro um tubinho a dar
assistência e outro é por onde vai
vão sair as balas querem cortar em um
eixo de 18 centímetros
queremos parte mais frágil encaixe que o
tambor do jato a roda livramento e agora
vou encaixar na parte do carro ou por
cola perto do tambor não ponho mesmo
início por quando vocês foram empurrar o
cano até chegar perto do tambor a copa
vai ficar
a epo já vai estrear o sistema todo e
depois porém cola logo a seguir tem que
encaixar mourinho vai passar pelos três
segmentos para ficar tudo alinhado tá
evitando assim problemas na parte de
parar depois
agora estou fazer um gatilho que é
bastante simples do forma mais ou menos
do 1 e corta o pará mas que nesta
partida vou fazer um conforto que o
guarda mato
agora essa aí é aquela coisa por ter o
dedo é e onde é que eu vou cortar tem
que ser mesmo em quase 1 de kawaoka no
porquê porque lá nessa parte branca vai
ficar encaixadas os elásticos que vão
impulsionar as balsas é aí onde ele cola
rapidamente e antiga escola sec põe
outro lado também mas por um uma escola
porque eu voltei por depois não aguentou
a opção de lá para cá então fica lá o
elástico época cola é que o pode
arrebentar tão abusiva na copa
agora vou dar um reforço em que
basicamente só contornar o samba e funk
hospital mãe
vocês viram
depois dará forma vinculando para o
pacto porém quem cola em caixa uma parte
esperam que sei que depois vão fazendo
isso até o final
[Música]
não ponho cola toda a volta e que não
têm claro de uma vez porque é assim vai
dar problema então não fazerem
figueirinha e com paciência agora
próximo da área tirei aquela parte mais
frágil colo já está só falta mesmo fazer
o pistão e as bolas estão vocês cortam
um quadrado em jogo como se fosse uma
rifa porque ela tem que ser ligeiramente
mais pequeno para andar livremente
dentro dá para ele resumiu a cair e nem
com fita igualzinho a rifa irão a parte
mais frágil dobram assim que ela parta
ficar mais ou menos de dois centímetros
a cair aquela parte do bairro e prendem
com fita e veja onde é que eu vou cortar
o que estão a exagerar em caixa lino
para trás azul e onde começa o tambor
vocês concordam
agora vou por aqui cola nestas parte
também diminuir o atrito é muito
importante vocês podem coloque podem
usar super cola cola adesiva copa
madeira daquelas mesmo instantâneo fica
de plástico cai e nesta partida
extremamente importante
se vocês não quiserem que quando você
puxar o gatilho não vai sair por
enquanto está muito grande aí então se
quiserem já fica bom
agora eu cortei uma faixa com 427 em
outro lado e 400 do outro e ver o
usuário da parte maior para a parte mais
pequena em fita modo que sobra nenhum
centímetro mais domínio e cotton com
esta inclinação estava fica por fora vai
ajudar aqui bala fique preso e não caiu
até aí seja vocês podem incluir com a
arma podem deparar brincar no momento
envolve não ficar lá sempre vou encaixar
o pistão
acho que eu vou encaixar na parte branca
quando ele fabricado
e está pronto a usar em que achei as
bolas todas menos uma que é desta
maneira que vocês em caixa r
o show estão hold em caixa já está ok e
agora só tem precisa amar e tem 15
pessoal está muito bonita mas tem alguma
força então vocês têm que tomar alguma
precaução que não podem disparar contra
ninguém e devem usar óculos de proteção
então do sol que servem perfeitamente
e quando digo em alguma força pode
chegar aos 10 metros se você usar um
elástico convidado ou então ficar em
elástico fazendo alguns nós e que os
textos é e só chegamos o fim e espero
que tenham gostado se vocês quiserem
ajudar o canal é só deixar lá que se
inscrevam para acompanhar os próximos e
fitch é isso e trabalhar porque carro